At the beginning of this lesson we talked about car sharing and what classes
one might be able to use to implement a car sharing simulation. And we hit upon
the classes car and person. Let's go ahead and actually implement those
classes. So, we'll imagine a bunch of people that all gather at the departure
location. There's a long road, with destinations, that we'll just label 1, 2,
3, and so on. Each of the people wants to go to at one of these destinations.
Maybe this one wants to go to three, same with the others. And then, we'll have
cars, that also have destinations. Let's say this car wants to go to
destination 4, then of course, this car can pick up whatever passengers want to
go destination 1, 2, 3, or 4. But not one that wants to go further. And, of
course, the car can only load as many passengers as they have seats. Make that
one less because the driver also needs a seat. So, now we need to figure out
what are the responsibilities of the classes. Let's start with the person
class. A person should know their destination. In our stimulation we also
want to give names to people so, of course the person should know that too. A
car should be able to pick up a passenger provided, of course, and only the car
will know that whether there is room and whether the destination is on the way.
And, of course, there is another thing that a car should be able to do, it
should be able to drive. It looks like the person is the easy of the two, let's
look at that first. Here's the Person class. You can see we have two
properties, a person has a name and a destination property with a getter for
each of them. These are read-only properties. Once a person has been
constructed with a particular name and a particular destination, that doesn't
change. Remember, it's just a simulation, these are not real people but, just
objects for use in our simulation program. Here is the Car class. Most
importantly, a car collects passengers. A car also knows how many seats it has.
The name of the driver, we'll just use that for reporting. The current
location, it starts at zero and goes up by one every time that the car drives
to the next location. And that is destination. We construct a car with a driver
name, number of seats and the destination. Initially it has no passengers and
is at location 0. So, now it's your turn. I'd like you to implement the
tryToAdd method. Where we add a person to the car, at least we try because if
there's no room or the passenger wants to go further than the car wants to go,
then it's not going to work. In that case, you shouldn't add p to the passenger
array list, but you should return false. On the other hand if you can't
accommodate the person. Go ahead and add it and return true.